hello everyone and welcome to round 2 of
the 2018 Sinquefield Cup now we have a
really a brutal game between Magnus
Carlsen and Savior Carrick in world
world champion and the 2016 World Chess
Championship challenger sorry I'm
uploading it so late but I I was at the
hospital all day but before we check out
the game we do have a nice photo channel
this will perhaps be the hardest photo
challenge you've ever faced so best of
luck to everyone there it is it's a nice
photo by David Lada featured in his the
thinker's so I don't know how many of
you will be able to crack this but like
I said best of luck to everyone and we
do have a nice photo by Leonard tose of
this encounter there you have it so we
can get in the mood and it will be a
very nice game that will also get us in
the mood for the Fisher Larson series as
what Carson did in this game is
something both Fisher and Larson had to
do for their entire careers careers as
as if you were an American in those days
and wanted to make a living by playing
chess then you could not afford you know
quick draws you had to play every
position for a win so let's check it out
Carlson has the white pieces and he
opens with c4 English opening e6 Knight
to c3 and the immediate Bishop to b4 we
have g3 Knight to f6 Bishop to g2
castles back Otakon Knight to f3 d5 a 3
now kurakin goes back with the bishop
Bishop to e7 in the d4 now D captures on
c4 95 this is all standard theory Knight
to c6 Bishop captures on c6 pawn
captures and Knight captures on c6 but
attacking both the Queen and the bishop
Queen e8 attacking the knight Knight
captures Queen captures and here we have
Queen to a4 Kerrigan replies with c5 and
this is perhaps where the game really
starts after this c5 replied by kurakin
unmoved unmoved 12 because in 2016 Cara
can already had this position on the
board that he played against moisei inko
witted the black pieces and here Cara
can replied the boy Sankar replied with
Queen captures on c4 and that game ended
in a draw it was a blitz
so it's hard to say if caro-kann
remembers this probably he does but it's
also very interesting the date Carson
check this game out and he did he
prepared his his reply you know in
regards to that game
so instead Carson doesn't go for Queen
captures on c4 which was played the
plenty of time not only in the muy Seca
versus Cara King game rather he goes for
D captures on c5 so here we have a game
that was never played Queen captures on
c5 and now Bishop to e3 seems like a
very logical move you develop the bishop
would a temple on the Queen Queen has to
move
but then again you're blocking your e to
pawn but as it is a an ancient
suggestion it could mean that cousin did
prepare this for the game so k Queen to
c7 we have rook to d1 and then out comes
Knight to d5 offering a trade of knights
but also attacking the bishop here
Bishop to b4 so this was the plan but
should be 3 to d4 now you are welcome to
push or a pawn we have looked at the 8th
and here Knight captures on d5 a very
interesting decision also possible was
efore here but perhaps here cross and
didn't like this Bishop to d7 idea with
an attack on his Queen after the Queen
moves Knight captures Queen captures and
now f6 and it seems that black would be
perfectly okay here after Castle c5 is
coming Bishop e3 Bishop to e6 and white
if white would not have anything here
so after rook to the 8th we have Knight
captures on d5 he captures on d5 and now
Queen to c2 again Carlson presents
kurakin with the opportunity to go for
for a nice attack and a really
complicated position here if I had this
position on the board and I played the
black pieces I would play Bishop to h3
instantly I wouldn't care if it's a good
move I will just play it because I
wanted the white king to stay in the
center but although this is the engines
favorite choice it leads to a very
complicated game for example f3 making
room for the king we have f6 King to f2
and now rook to e8 and here white has a
couple of options but one of the nicer
ones is g4 so you actually try
the bishop here although there's no way
to capture it immediately because the
Queen is guarding the g3 square but now
for example if h5 is played you have to
see that the G captures on h5 is fine
and now it will be white as well that
will have options for attacking here but
yeah an extremely complicated game which
kirkin doesn't go for he's not looking
for adventure
so instead Queen to e7 he wants to
develop his pieces play rogue d7 he
wants to bring over this rook over to e8
and create pressure against the D along
the e-file so okay
castles beshrew h3 only now now comes
Luke 2 e 1 and here rook to d7
Bushra back to C 3 rook to e8 and now
comes rope to d4 Queen to g5 by kurakin
and here Carlsen goes for Queen to d2 he
offers a trade of Queens which gives a
pretty equal position which he can play
for as long as he is as he pleases
there is also a quite a forced line
efore but Carson doesn't doesn't go for
it for example you have to find a queen
to g4 for black and see that this will
be a threat Queen of 3 - G - checkmate
and now of course while play while we
play Queen to g4 you are also giving
more protection to the rook on d7 but
now why it also has a very nice reply
rook to e3 after the capture sunny for
also you have to find f3 for white of
course this point is pinned you cannot
capture because rook captures any 8 and
now I have to remove the Queen then you
get
rookie characters on e4 rook captures an
e4 Queen captures an e4 Queen captures a
need for rook captures on e4 now your C
pawn is under attack you have to bring
your bishop back to defend it we would
reach this position where a white pawn
structure is a bit better but bishops
are of opposite colors - rooks are still
on the board white would have a slight
advantage here probably if cousin found
this hidden I think that he could push
for advantage here so instead a simple
Queen d2 or offering a queen trade which
kirkin accepts Queen captures but we
have rook captures and now comes better
back to e6
we have rook to d1 rogue d2 e7 and
outcomes f 385
we have King to have to improving the
of the King f6 and now Rock the d4 a
nice rock lift the rock is on a nice
dark square car cane will not be able to
oppose it here King to h7 now rook 1 - D
- Bishop to f7 h3 we have a six rook to
a4 and now King back to g8 push up to d4
we have king - h7 Bishop back to c3
Carlton repeats King to g8 and here
I've crossed I would repeat Bishop to d4
he would you know basically stated that
he's satisfied with the draw in this
game but you know why not play plate a
bit more as he already had a chance and
move 25 when the Queen's were exchanged
it's a pretty draw position you can you
know offer grandmasters draw there now
it's moved 33 also if you repeat the
bishop to d4 you you can easily draw the
game here but you know why not play it a
bit longer so g4 h factors on g4 h
captors on g4 and King to h7 now okay
rook to a5 and here kirkin played Rock
to b7 which in itself is not a mistake
but it allows constant to do something
that will allow him to continue the game
wanting something more than a draw here
cross and played rook captures on d5 he
sacrificed the exchange for a pawn
so okay you have to capture the rock
Bishop captures rook captures and here
this is now where Cara can really takes
a wrong turn here he played King to g6
for some reason he allowed rook to c5
and capturing of the c4 pawn perhaps he
didn't enjoy rook to c7 defending the
pawn and now I have to rope the d6
attacking the a6 pawn perhaps he saw
that rook to e8 and now both of his
works would be pretty passive defending
the two isolated points but in fact he
had rooked
rook this rook to e7 would an attack
against the e pawn and after white
pushes e4 rope to e6 and now you either
force an exchange or White has to go
back
for example rook to d5 now you go rock
c6 again you don't allow white to
threaten the c4 pawn rook to d7
for example King to h6 and now comes g5
this comes with check King captures and
rook captures on g7 so although it would
be perhaps a bit unpleasant for black
black can hold this so it's hard to say
which of the variations Harkins saw or
didn't but he played King to g6 and okay
across and immediately goes rook c5 now
he will win the c4 pawn as well so a
sacrifice exchanged for two points is
already very nice we have looked to h8
and now comes King g3 not capturing
immediately and allow this rope to h2
check King moves and now rook to e7 e
for okay you don't lose material but
another king is completely cut off from
the game you will not be able to push
this for anything
so after rook to h8 King g3 first
preventing rook H to rope the b6 and
only now rook captures on c4 now cousin
has two points for the exchange and this
is already very nice but it's also not
all that clear how you will push for
advantage here so let's see how he does
it rook to h1 now comes Rock to c7 rook
the c1 we have worked to d7 now
controlling the D the open D file rook
to c6 and now a four rock to g1 check
King to f2 now comes rook to a one
attacking the pawn on e4 and now a5 now
the position on the Queen side is
completely blocked here the bishop is
controlling both of these points and
Kirkenes two rooks are powerless to do
anything on the on the Queen side so now
to push Kirk across and has to improve
the position on the King side as well
rook to a4 was played now comes King to
g3 rook 8 the c4 now comes Luke to a7
controlling this rook not allowing it to
move from the 6th rank rook to e6 now
comes
c4 as the pond was attacked on E - but
you also have to prepare to push
we have roped the c8 and now comes a
rook to d7 rookie to c6 and now f4 f5 is
now definitely a threat for example
rook 8 the c7 was played here but you
don't if you play something like rook
captures on c3 I would an idea of giving
back
changed kind of relieve the pressure it
doesn't work because after King to h4
you are lost here for example rook to a3
now comes f5 with check King moves now
comes g5 and after captures you play
King to h5 Rakesh three check King
captures and now of course this will be
this will be winning for white
so after this f4 move we have rook eight
to c7 here Kara can offers a trade of
rooks cross and of course declines this
f5 first this comes with check for King
to h7 and now comes Luke to d8 rook the
c8 we have looked back to be three and
now rook to e8 rook to d4 adding
protection to d4 pawn and now rook the
c7 if you tried something like rook see
the c8 here with an idea of exchanging
rooks with rook to the eighth cousin can
simply go something like King to f3
after you do this and then comes the
rook to be four after you move it back
now rook to b6 and now you welcome the
exchange of rooks and also attack the a6
pawn and if captures captures rook to b8
then Bishop d4 defense and this will of
course now be a winning endgame for
white so after loop to d4 Brooke to c7
and now comes King to f4 rook c-37
pressuring d4 pawn but now rook to sea
for King to h6 King to f3
we have rook to these seven and now
comes Bishop to d4 with some nice ideas
King back to h7 we have B for now
rook to d6 and now King back to III King
to h6 and now rook to c1 now here we
have to be very careful Kerrigan goes
back a king to h7 if instead you try
something like rook e - d 8 would an
attack on the bishop and then you get
the rook to h1 check King to g5 and now
King to f3 a very nice move you're
threatening rook to h5 checkmate and if
you prevent this only move to prevent
this g6 for example then you get Bishop
to e3 checkmate
so you have to be very careful here so I
have to rope the c1 Kerrigan goes back
King to h7 we have rush up to b6 and
rope to d7 now Bishop to c5 by Carlsen
if you try something like rook to see
sex which is also an idea you allow up
to d1 and then even though you can move
this Bushmen capture the a sex point of
this rook can check the why think anyone
and then grab the e4 pawn so okay rook
d7 we have brush up the c5 and now comes
look to d8 and now rook to h1 check King
g8 and now King to f4 rook to e8 we have
rook to e1 now comes g5 with check and
now pawn captures on g6 AMPAS on King to
g7 and now g5 King captures pawn
captures King captures in the now comes
rope to h1 rook to f7 a very nice idea
now rook to h6 check will not be a
winner DSX pawn but rather it will lose
you the game this opens up a discovered
attack and you lose the rope here for
example King III King captures on h6
rocked f7 was played in outcome scheme
to e3 King to e6 and now rook to h4 rook
to f6 now not allowing any checks on f6
we have rope to h7 and now rope to f7
blocking rub back to h5 we have King to
d7 and now II five simply pushing the
passed pawn we have rook to f1 King to
e4 and here is the most critical moment
in the game but you know you you know
you can't blame anyone in this situation
here they have already been playing for
six and a half hours I wouldn't move
like rook to e6 you still prevent moves
like rook to h6 and das exponents
protected this is a deadly drawing a em
game but after this King to e4 move
Carrick and played King to c6 and again
you can't blame him he's been playing
for six and a half hours and although he
was named the Minister of Defence here
the the minister seems to have failed
this is a losing idea because here we
have rook to h6 check and of course car
can probably saw this king b5 we have
worked to b6 check King to c4 and here
Cara can probably saw in his
calculations that rook captures on a6
well not pretty much do anything for
white because of rook to e1 check forces
a draw
King at five rook captures on e5 King
moves to f6 and now rook captures here
pawn capture screen captures and this is
a even though it's a
it's a dare to draw because the rook is
completely cutting off the king from
entering the game so okay after King to
c4
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the move Kerrigan missed
across and of course did not play rook
captures rather try to pause the video
here and find it the move crossing place
to end win this game so for those of you
who found it congratulations you are you
are an engine sir and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show here
cross and played pawn to e6 and now you
can see that the pawn is a further
protected and you will not be able to
win it kurakin did try rook to e1 check
was playing but now King to f5 the point
is guarded twice rope to f1 check we
have kinky five rope to e1 check King to
f6 rope to f1 check King to g7 and now
rook to e8 there's no point in further
checking the King because the G 1 square
is guarded by the bishop so rook to e8
was played we have e 7 now and now rook
to e1 King to f7 was played here and
here rook to e4 it doesn't help you rock
the f1 check you simply play rook to f6
you can blog to check and then of course
you will simply play a pawn here and
bring the Queen into the game King of 7
we have rook to e4
now comes rope to d6 Rock to h8 as there
is really nothing to do here checking
will also result in a block by the roof
so rope to H it was played here probably
you know there's really nothing to do
here anymore across and played simply
rook captures on a6 and it was in this
position and move 88 that Sarah Kerrigan
resigned to the game there's really
nothing to do here car across and is now
three pawns up and I mean yet again
Carson creates this beautiful
masterpiece that really shows you that
it doesn't matter that the position is
drawn the position is basically drawn on
the first move as well you know you the
positions are the same you know a chance
chances are equal but such is the same
that position is the same thing even if
you enter an equal endgame you know one
player can still make a less remove and
then the other player can you know take
advantage of this such was the case it's
still like all the way the
of the game where were a car cane
allowed Carson to sacrifice the exchange
and go for something more but you know
who would who think this would happen
so yeah before I forget I did prepare
the standings after round two so now you
can see that Carson also joined the lead
with one and a half points the leaders
Levon Aronian and Schanker momiji are
both through their games so now we have
a three man tie with our enemy medium
and magnus carlsen then we have Hikaru
Nakamura grief shook Maxima shoulder
graph
Vishwanath Anand and Fabiano Khurana at
one point Wesley so would one draw and
Sarah Kerrigan who so far lost lost both
of his games to Mahmoud your event the
Coulson so yeah not the greatest start
to the tournament for Sergei Kuryakin
but you know he always brings his game
later later in the tournament so yeah
definitely I was very happy to show you
this game as it is really a great
preparation for the Fisher Larsen series
because this is how both of them had to
play in those days but we're gonna talk
about that some more when I finally
started the series so I would like to
thank John Fogerty John Schaefer more
its Nance Gil Theresa and Colin
McConnell for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon with
hopefully another interesting video see
you soon